When you think of Disney and its characters,
the first things that spring to mind are generally
happy thoughts - pretty much all of Disney's
properties are aimed at children, after all.
But there's actually an extremely dark side
to the company that describes its theme parks
as "the happiest places on Earth".
If you look closely at some of the most well-known
characters in Disney stories, you'll actually
see that there are some very troubled individuals
who are in desperate need of seeing a shrink.
From manic depressives and schizophrenics,
to xenophobes and compulsive liars, this video
will take a look at a variety of characters
with such issues.
Here are ten Disney characters with serious
mental disorders.
Pinocchio
Pinocchio is the name of the wooden puppet
boy in the movie of the same name.
He is brought to life by a fairy and told
that he could become a real boy if he is brave,
truthful and unselfish.
Unfortunately, this proves to be difficult
for Pinocchio, as he's actually a compulsive
pathological liar.
It's kind of his thing and, of course, his
nose famously grows whenever he tells a lie
- but he just can't help himself and it keeps
growing and growing, even when his "conscience",
Jiminy Cricket, is telling him to speak the
truth.
Peter Pan
Peter Pan is the only character on this list
who has a condition that has gone on to be
named after him - that condition is, of course,
Peter Pan syndrome.
The protagonist of his self-titled story,
he's the boy who never grows up and is, therefore,
very socially immature.
He wants to continue enjoying the care-free
pleasures of childhood, even though he's actually
an adult.
To Peter, time means nothing.
His life, in his mind at least, is all about
fun, whimsy and adventure - but this isn't
always a good thing, as he can be impractical
and conceited at times, which can lead to
him getting himself into dangerous situations.
Eeyore
There's a legitimate argument that every character
in Hundred Acre Wood - even Winnie-the-Pooh
himself - suffers from some kind of mental
disorder; Tigger has Attention Deficit Disorder
and Piglet has terrible anxiety, for example.
But we don't want to fill a video with them,
so we'll stick to the most obvious example.
Eeyore the donkey lives his life in a state
of constant pessimism.
He is quite literally unable to appreciate
life's smallest and most basic pleasures due
to his crippling depression.
You only have to hear his miserable voice
to appreciate how depressed the poor guy is
- although he doesn't really speak that often,
as his depression keeps him quiet a lot of
the time.
The Evil Queen
The Evil Queen from Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs displays textbook narcissism - a personality
disorder that is characterized by exaggerated
feelings of self-importance, an excessive
need for admiration, extreme vanity and selfishness,
and a total lack of empathy for others.
Her narcissism is most clearly evident in
the famous scene in which she asks her magic
mirror who the fairest one of all is.
Expecting the answer to be herself, when she
doesn't get the answer she wants, her jealousy
of Snow White's superior beauty leads her
to become murderous, which would also suggests
that she is something of a psychopath.
Basically, the lady has issues!
Ariel
The main character of Disney's classic The
Little Mermaid, Ariel, actually suffers from
a number of serious mental disorders.
First of all, she's a chronic kleptomaniac
and hoarder.
Being obsessed with the human world, Ariel
spends a lot of time acquiring - or should
we say stealing - objects used by humans,
and she has a huge collection of them that
she simply refuses to get rid of.
But her biggest issue is her severe body dysmorphia.
Ariel believes her mermaid body is defective
and needs to be "fixed".
As a result, she undergoes a mystical form
of cosmetic surgery to have her lower body
transformed from the tail of a fish into the
legs of a human.
The poor girl really does have a lot of problems!
King Triton
King Triton is Ariel's father in The Little
Mermaid.
The ruler of Atlantica has severe Xenophobia
and calls humans “barbarians” and “dangerous”
- he even has genocidal thoughts about us
Homo sapiens.
Come on, Triton, we're not that bad!
The powerful trident-wielding monarch also
has some serious anger-management problems
and is prone to extremely violent outbursts
- such as the time he callously destroyed
the human artefacts that Ariel had "acquired"
as a way of trying to get through to her.
His aggressive actions and prejudice attitude
towards humans ended up putting a huge strain
on his relationship with his daughter, which
is never a good thing.
Scar
Scar is an evil lion and the main antagonist
of The Lion King movie.
He is the brother of Mufasa and the uncle
of Simba - and he suffers from more than one
fairly serious mental condition.
First and foremost, he's a complete sociopath;
he killed his own brother and attempted to
kill his nephew, and at the same time he also
possesses that unsettling creepy charm associated
with so many real-life killers.
But he also has a dangerously narcissistic
personality disorder, in the sense that he
expects people to treat him as their superior,
will stop at nothing in his aggressive quest
to gain power, and doesn't care about the
devastation his actions cause in the process.
Cruella de Ville
Simply put, Cruella de Ville is a psycopath.
The villain of One Hundred and One Dalmatians
takes pleasure in being cruel to animals - which
is a classic early indicator in diagnosing
psychopaths.
In the real world, countless people who have
gone on to become serial killers started out
harming animals - giving themselves a taste
of the power it made them feel - before moving
onto killing their fellow humans.
Cruella de Ville has absolutely no empathy
for the puppies she wants to kill in order
to make the perfect fur coat - and the fact
that her reason for wanting to kill innocent
animals is for the sake of making an item
of clothing only further emphasises how psychopathic
she is.
Captain Hook
The villain of the classic tale of Peter Pan,
Captain Hook famously has a hook for hand,
after his real hand was chopped off by Pan
and fed to a crocodile.
As a result, Hook suffers from post-traumatic
stress disorder - a condition that is made
worse by the fact that the crocodile that
ate his hand constantly follows him around,
after having got a taste for the pirate's
blood.
What heightens the condition further is the
fact that the crocodile has an alarm clock
in its belly, so its presence is always accompanied
by a ticking sound.
Is it any wonder that Hook acts how he does?
His anger, his obsessive thirst for vengeance
on Pan and his constant state of jumpiness
is caused by a horrific event that persistently
haunts him.
Elsa
Elsa - one of the main characters in the hugely
successful Disney movie Frozen - was born
with the magical ability to produce and manipulate
ice and snow.
Her early inability to control her powers
resulted in some terrible events - such as
nearly killing her own sister.
As a result, Elsa developed disorders like
paranoia and agoraphobia.
The paranoia rendered her terrified of using
her powers for fear of causing more incidents
like the one in which she injured her sister,
and the agoraphobia caused her to shut herself
away from society in order to ensure she didn't
hurt anybody else.
Of course, after ultimately learning that
love was the key to controlling her powers,
she got over her issues, but she certainly
had them for a long time.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 Disney
characters with serious mental disorders.
Can you think of any others?
Did we leave any major examples out?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one!